Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and because a
big teaser for the Telltale Game of Thrones
video game just dropped, this week’s bonus
video is going to be all about that.
So I’ll explain what the game is all about,
what the teaser was and how it’s all going
to fit into the expanded song of ice and fire
universe.
Even though this isn’t strictly a book or
show related video the weekly giveaway is
still running.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
So, important stuff first, If you’ve never
heard about it, Telltale Games is making a
narrative video game series based on A Song
of Ice and Fire.
It’s a series, meaning instead of a linear
JRPG game like Final Fantasy that releases
sequels, the Game of Thrones game will have
seasons.
Inside each season new content or episodes
will be released in the form of a continuing
narrative.
So think of each song of ice and fire book
as a season of the game.
Seasons of the telltale game will be released
about once a year.
Within each season there will be 4 to 5 episodes.
So if one book is like a season, the entire
season will be released over the course of
a year in each of those episode installments.
A lot of you might have played the Walking
Dead Telltale game.
They’re getting ready to release season
3 of that.
The Game of Thrones game will work exactly
like that.
Since I’ll be doing a weekly walking dead
giveaway while I make tv videos for that show,
I might give out steam codes for free copies.
Playing the Walking Dead Telltale game is
probably the best way to get prepared for
the Game of Thrones version.
It will be mostly the same mechanics.
A lot of you asked how the game is going to
fit into the canon.
It’s going to have the same relationship
with the books as the show does.
It will take characters from the novels and
write a story arc that loosely follows the
direction of the books.
In reality, when we’re all playing it, the
game will feel like more of a side story.
You know how George RR Martin teased he might
write an 8th novel after Dream of Spring so
he has more room for side stories?
Think of the telltale game as one giant side
story.
Right now they’re still writing the story
of the game.
The person they hired to create it is the
same person who wrote the story for Destiny.
Because of the way telltale games narratives
work, they have this choose your own adventure
model, decisions you make in episode 1 of
the game will affect the story in later episodes.
From a development standpoint, the game is
still in alpha.
It’s not open to beta testers yet.
The early release date estimates are December
2014.
There have not been any major delay announcements.
Until we hear otherwise, plan on a December
release.
Each episode patch usually comes every two
to three months, and new seasons once a year.
For those of you suffering from game of thrones
withdrawal during the off season.
This game will be your drug of choice.
Book readers will enjoy it because of the
story based element.
Which George RR Martin’s inner circle is
consulting on, and people that only watch
the show will love it for including elements
from the show.
I know it would be awesome if actors from
the show voiced versions of their characters
in the game, but don’t expect that.
The Walking Dead Game mostly focused on new
characters, not people from the tv show.
Which characters are going to be in the Game
Of Thrones game?
Right now the teaser they released focuses
on a Asha Greyjoy quote and House Forrester.
It was this one card with the quote.
It’s not even a trailer.
They released it because PAX is going on right
now, but they haven’t shown off any gameplay
yet.
Because of the quote Iron From Ice, and the
fact House Forrester is in Bold.
It’s believed that the Telltale Game will
focus primarily on the Ironborn and House
Forrester in the North.
In terms of where the story picks up inside
the game.
The quote and House Forrester indicate it
will be during Book 5, Dance with Dragons.
In order to provide more backstory I’m going
to have to get into spoilers from Book 5.
So careful in case you don’t want to know
anything.
I’ll leave this spoiler tag up.
You can either turn the volume down or just
skip forward in the video till you don’t
see the tag anymore...okay, everybody ready.
Here we go.
House Forrester only appears in book 5 when
Lady Sybell, Stannis’ Queen provides scouts
from their house to aid Stannis’ Army as
they march through the Wolfswood from Deepwood
Motte to Winterfell.
Stannis is marching on Winterfell to deal
with the Boltons.
It’s a big deal, thus the spoiler warnings.
No known member of House Forrester has appeared
in the books or on the show yet.
Presumably they’ll show up in Winds of Winter.
The Iron From Ice Quote is spoken by asha
greyjoy.
She becomes a captive of Stannis at Deepwood
Motte along with her ironborn soldiers.
This all points to the story in the game focusing
on the events surrounding stannis’ journey
to winterfell.
Because all of the Walking Dead game and clementine,
it’s likely that Telltale will create a
new character from House Forrester or an Iron
Born character to be the protagonist.
Someone new but that fits into the larger
story of the books and the show.
The battle for Winterfell is a Winds of Winter
thing, so no word on whether or not season
1 of the video game will go that far.
But the story will focus on the happenings
between deepwood motte and winterfell.
Okay, spoilers over.
I will be doing let’s play videos for this.
I’m almost done moving into my new apartment
and my goal is to have my gaming channel up
and running by the end of the year.
It’s just called charliestreams.
There’s a link on my homepage but I’ll
add one in the description too.
I’ll still be doing weekly book and tv show
videos on this channel, I’ll just also start
doing video game videos for the game of thrones
game on my gaming channel.
Just as fun bonus content for people that
like that.
Like I said though, the game isn’t coming
till december.
I might be able to get a beta copy before
that to do some preview videos for.
But I’ll keep you posted as that gets figured
out.
I will be doing a Q&A video for this tonight,
So please submit all your questions.
They don’t just have to be about the video
game.
I’ll also announce a giveaway winner for
this week.
Right now click here to get that.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it and click here to learn all about the gods
and religions in song of ice and fire.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!